at linkedin's flagship office space
there are more than 75 different types
of seating
this feels like a spot for maybe a
really quick call or just
answering a couple of emails work
or nba jam yeah this is your space yeah
this is my space and that's your space
many of these seats were actually meant
to be desks so i think
during our initial plans we had just
standard desks in this space with
traditional conference rooms and huddle
rooms but the pandemic changed that how
much of what we're seeing in this space
is new as a result of the pandemic 100
of it this recently opened space is
designed for hybrid work a model that
has emerged as the leading choice for
linkedin and others with 42 percent of
people with remote capable jobs working
partly at home according to a february
gallup poll
so what does a hybrid office look like i
toured building one with the project's
leaders to find out and to get a glimpse
into what could be the future of
workplace design
building one is the new hub of
linkedin's campus in silicon valley it
has six floors roughly 239 thousand
square feet and room for about 1500
employees prior to the pandemic when we
looked at this building really at that
point the main goal was fitting as many
people as we could in this space the
original floor plans called for 1080
individual workstations the thinking was
what employee one desk once we were sent
home during the pandemic you know a lot
of that changed and much of what we were
trying to solve for before the pandemic
was not the same
thing that we were looking at at that
moment so with the help of its design
partners at nbbj linkedin retooled the
space cutting the number of desks in
half to 569 workstations and adding
dozens of new non-traditional seating
setups what did you and linkedin learn
from the pandemic that would result in
the space that we're in right now i
think we really wanted to do a lot of
experimentation because we just didn't
know no one had a crystal ball about
what the future would actually be so we
wanted to provide as many variety of
spaces as possible
the variety starts right when employees
walk in
the design does away with a large lobby
in favor of a cafe daniel and adam
this is one of my favorite spaces of the
buildings the idea of this space is that
the minute you walk in you feel the buzz
there's people getting coffee there's
people moving throughout the space the
cafe spills into the first of two areas
linkedin calls its co-working spaces
pink open non-reserved seating the
co-working area on the second floor was
added in the redesign so we've got
primary work points here desks with
monitors and tall backed boots with
ottomans dot the space that looking back
at the original design was once full of
assigned workstations
so a space like this is great for those
like smaller time periods where you
might come in and like work with your
team and then go home and do some focus
time or vice versa yeah and that's okay
with linkedin to to come in for half the
day and work at home for half the day
yeah linkedin's approach is that we
are leading with trust
the idea is that we trust our employees
to make the decision
that's going to be best for them and
their teams co-working is open to anyone
in the company for any amount of time
employees assigned to the building who
plan to work there all day will likely
move upstairs the concept behind how the
floors are planned is the entry to the
building is the most social and the
farther that you get into the space it
becomes more focused workers sit in
so-called neighborhoods or areas
assigned to their teams we call this the
living room neighborhoods are split
about half alternative workspaces and
half traditional desks those desks are
mostly here in the back was this sort of
what the whole floor was meant to look
like before the pandemic it is what the
whole floor looked like before the
pandemic what led the decision to get
rid of desk space because we imagined
that not everyone was going to come to
work eight hours a day so rather than
fill the space with potentially empty
desks of which i still saw plenty new
furniture was added based on something
called the postures matrix the postures
matrix is about the amount of time that
we imagine a person would be working
doing a certain activity combined with
the amount of ergonomics to support that
so how long am i meant to spend at this
chair here so as a high table we imagine
that you spend less time compared to a
low standard table so this would this
would be used maybe 30 to 60 minutes
linkedin employees in building one don't
have assigned desks instead they can
grab a seat anywhere in their
neighborhood but it's not quite hot
desking either as seats don't need to be
reserved even before the pandemic our
desk utilization was i think was around
30 to 40 percent 30 to 40 percent
meaning that like
even though people might be in the
office all day they're at meetings
they're at lunch they might be sick
right or just not in the office and so
now we're really looking at what does
that desk utilization look like in a
hybrid world do you know what that is
yet no
but in a hybrid office the individual
setup is arguably easier to design for
it's the conference room that's tricky
here linkedin is again experimenting
from conference rooms that look like
living rooms what we wanted to do is to
take away the formality of meetings from
off-site to on-site and put people in a
neutral position where where if you are
at home as a part of the conversation
you're feeling very comfortable
interacting with your colleagues to
conference rooms packed with tech
including cameras positioned at table
height that reframe to better show the
speaker so it makes it a little bit more
like you're sitting at the table and
cameras that help make the physical
digital when folks are actually writing
on the on this
on this white board typically what you
would be doing is writing like this and
a camera would be behind you shadowing
you from other people from seeing what
it is that you're actually able to see
actually what's going on this technology
ghosts you out so that people that are
remote can see what you're writing can
we test it let's do it all right
i'm standing in front of it now see
what's capturing yeah i see what you
mean
so you have this new space with all of
these new bits of technology and
different types of seating is it meant
to encourage people to come back into
the office
um i think it's meant to
welcome people
if that's where they need to be but if
that person is gonna do their best work
and have their best contributions to
their team while being remote that's
okay
that flexibility may not be possible for
some companies and others like tesla
simply aren't interested but linkedin
sees building one as a kind of test one
that others could learn from to what
extent is what we're seeing here in
linkedin's office the future of work
what we have is an awesome opportunity
to experiment and to see what happens
over time and that this is entirely
flexible space it might turn out that
what we need are more desks in the
future and that this could be changed
into that or it might turn into a
completely different model but the
experimentation and the observation is
really the key to seeing what the future
is
[Music]